pathetisch
bösartig
auch pathetisch
hmm frances verführerisch schrecklich
[Musik]
wow wow wow das will im jahr 2017 und
über das reden wir ja wenn sowie aus
gast 2018 geht war für mich ein ziemlich
enttäuschendes film ja und ich finde das
spiegelt sich auch in den nominierungen
wieder während des jahres hatte man ja
den eindruck dass werden kommt noch mal
irgendwann mutter tanja jetzt wenn ich
diese liste mir angucke denke ich war
nicht so dass ich mir für dieses jahr
wünsche naja natürlich sehr viel mehr
gute filme müssen gar nicht aus amerika
kommen defektes hollywood natürlich
schon so etwas wieder gradmesser für das
filmgeschäft sehr viele sehr
unterschiedliche sachen
und darum ist es toll wenn hollywood
auch wieder richtig gute filme
produziert womit ich nicht sagen will
dass es keine gegeben hat letztes jahr
aber ich habe sie etwas mehr suchen
müssen als es bislang der fall war also
der wirklich beste regisseur aber
natürlich dessen thesen mit dem antoni
film aber weil der nicht nominiert ist
gemalto reporter derjenige den ich für
den besten regisseur halte fehlt nämlich
der regisseur von trier wilmots auszeit
erbringe sowie peter mcgough
dementsprechend wird es natürlich
guillermo del toro gewinnen denn dafür
ist ein shape of water ein wirklich
erschreckender ein wirklicher horrorfilm
in meinen augen einfach dann doch zu gut
gemacht bester regisseur hoffe ich in
diesem jahr auf gregor beck lady bird
ist das dein taufname warum steht ja in
anführungszeichen ich habe ihn mir
ausgesucht
sie hat sicherlich chancen nur man muss
bedenken bei hollywood wird nicht nach
rein politischen gesichtspunkten
abgestimmt sondern das spielen wiederum
auch interessen eine rolle die sich
glaube ich dann doch gegen jede art von
mito debatte oder irgendwie city wieder
durchsetzen werden und das ist dann doch
die liebe zum opulenten film und zum
spektakel und natürlich auch zum
kassenerfolg
und ich fürchte in all diesen drei
kategorien hat greta gerwig wenig zu
bieten
wenn sie es nicht wird würde ich mir
wünschen dass es john peel war der
regisseur von get out weil es ein
ungewöhnlicher film als junger film ist
ein junger regisseur ist ein schwarzes
und weil ich denke es sollte wirklich
und nicht vermutet dass auch das ist in
dieser ausgabe vor allen dingen
universität gehen wird und das würde
mich freuen
gute noch einen bruder zu sehen
ja natürlich ist es das
[Musik]
stimmt das nicht beim besten film ist es
für mich ganz eindeutig das solle bitte
doch unbedingt rebuild bauzeit missouri
sein erstaunlicherweise als ich eben mal
auf ein brett vor umgegangen bin ist er
auch mit abstand am besten dotiert ich
schätze sie sind entweder als mutter bin
ich bin dschawwad
ich muss zugeben ich hätte ein vermögen
aus shape of water gesetzt weil ich
glaube dass der so ziemlich alles
anspricht was die akademiemitglieder die
an alle stimmberechtigt sind an filmen
überhaupt interessiert
der beste film ist mein pony aber er ist
nicht nominiert also shape of water weil
der ist so ähnlich wie meine beton
[Musik]
wenn es kommen wird ich hochzufrieden
wenn es regellaufzeit emission wird
würde ich mich wahnsinnig freuen
und wenn es schepperte wird wäre ich
auch richtig glücklich insofern kann mir
eigentlich in der oscar-nacht mich viel
passieren außer das dessauer oder fern
teams vielleicht diesen preis
gewinnseitig aber doch auch nachdem
entscheidungen die bisher gefallen sind
in den gilden und so halte ich es
eigentlich für völlig ausgeschlossen